we're partnering up with the iran
institute this week and joining me in
studio or two of their top intellectuals
Tara Smith and Ankara got a welcome to
the Rubin report we're going to be
talking about selfishness and the virtue
of selfishness
how could selfishness possibly be
virtuous I thought selfishness was evil
how could it not be virtue I love love
talking about selfishness I found the
two and it's going pretty well yeah what
I mean part of what I mean by that is in
a sense you know it works for me it
works if you want people to be happy I
mean I'll give you one quick kind of
capsule just to get us going if you care
about people's being happy genuinely
having fulfilling lives you know feeling
good about their lives but with good
reason to feel good about their lives
then I think you need to people need to
think carefully about what's in my best
interest and that's largely what
selfishness is all about doing what's
really gonna be good for you best for
you so that you can have the best life
that you can have I mean you're gonna
have to I can go on and on that's why
that's why we're here you may have to
interrupt sometimes alright so um when I
ran sort of first was writing about this
it was pretty radical to say selfishness
was virtuous right yeah I mean I think
it still is it may be more radical now
at some level she's basically the only
person who will say that selfishness is
a virtue and people often say well look
we obviously know that it's a vice you
know all kinds of people that you label
is sob they're cheaters they cut corners
in their work they're always trying to
take advantage of other people and she
has a completely different conception of
what it means to be selfish what she
thinks about those people is they're
actually not pursuing what's in their
self-interest they're not doing anything
that's gonna make them happy and if you
really took seriously that it's your
life you have one life to live I'm
trying to make the most of it you would
not act like that and I think even more
important
she thinks about it is that we bundled
together into the concept so the idea of
selfishness so that used cars salesman
who cuts corners he should put the old
domitor back in with and he's trying to
cheat his customers we put that together
with the Bill Gates who's labeled as
selfish because he makes doodles and
oodles of money but he makes it he
doesn't steal it he doesn't cheat his
customers he's offering a tremendous
value we call a kid who wants to just
play with his toys and doesn't want to
share maybe he's saved for a year to buy
a bike and now he wants to use it and
someone who hasn't done anything who
comes by and you're well he doesn't have
a bike you have a bike so you're
supposed to share like why and we put
all this together all these people are
selfish and some of these people are bad
and some of these people are profoundly
good you can't think with that kind of
we have a very clearly vocabulary yeah
for bad behavior so we just throw it all
oh it's all selfish well no not if
you're really thinking about what is in
your self-interest now a lot of that
behavior is bad and should be condemned
but because it's inconsiderate or
non-objective about the other person or
abusive in some case I mean there's all
sorts of bad exploitative behavior and
I'm Rand is certainly against that but
doing what's good for you and sometimes
that means turning away the appeal of
somebody else you know or oh but this
person needs it or this other person is
more important than you it's like no my
life is the most important thing to me
just as yours should be to you and just
as yours should be to you and in fact
that's really the only path by which
people can lead the kinds of fulfilling
lives and rewarding lives and genuinely
good lives so one of the things that I
really like to do on this show is is
define words because especially these
days we live in a time where everyone's
sort of defining words or ideas their
own way so partly what we're talking
about here is a sort of misunderstanding
in a modern sense of what the word
selfish means right then how what's the
best way if you wanted to lay out what
that other person is the the used-car
salesman who's not really there acting
selfishly at some level but that but
they're really not would be the I'm
rands argument because they're not doing
what's in their best interest
by cheating their customers it's
probably not best for them you know I'm
not sure that there's always gonna be a
term that's a you know a single best
term to use for some of these cases I
ran two advocates of what she calls
rational selfishness it's got to be
thoughtful selfishness it's got to be
about what really is in my interest not
just long term but long term not just
today what's gonna make me feel good now
but all things considered I mean think
about for instance when you go to a
wedding and you wish the young couple
all the happiness in the world right all
the success in the world if you go to a
college graduation and you hope they
have a really successful life that's
good for them all right you're thinking
about I mean it's not that you hope
they'll do whatever will make them feel
good they'll get the right drugs and
they'll just be you know there'll be
some dumb and happy but they'll think
they're having a good life right so the
used-car salesman the cheater or the
Philander or some of these these creeps
right
I mean they've gotten into relationships
that then they're cheating on their
wives or whatever it might be you're
cheating on their clients is this I mean
if you step back and actually think
about it a little bit is that making
them a genuinely good life a genuinely
satisfying life I mean you'll read about
the made offs who were racked by not
just guilt but hating themselves the
entire time they're you know engaged in
the kinds of games that they're engaged
in it so it's not I think that there's
always going to be a single time again
in some cases it is something like that
was really inconsiderate of this but you
know it's Rhymes it's a small issue well
that was really non objective you
weren't realizing well from his point of
view and where he stands he had good
reason to be concerned about this and
you had good reason to be concerned
about that
and it's just one broader point true
well I do think some of this is about
what we mean by the term it's it's not
just all around is saying what everybody
else is saying but she's using the word
a little differently I mean she is
saying no radically different from just
about everybody else who talks about
ethics you know when she was writing
today forever your life is yours you
should make the most of it in a way
that's respectful of the fact that
other's lives are theirs and so on but
to do that you
to be focused primarily on the value of
your well-being to you and trying to
think about what's really gonna put
together a compose that mosaic that is
the best life for me so would it be fair
to say that acting in your own
self-interest is the most sort of it's
sort of the best way you can live if
personal responsibility is of primacy to
you if yeah if personal responsibility
and your own life so I think another way
of thinking about that she's advocating
selfishness and it's not the only term
she uses Tara was saying I mean rational
self-interest is another one and another
one is the pursuit of happiness but if
really taking that seriously it means
the pursuit of your own individual
happiness that that's what you should be
aiming at and part of I think what she's
when she's trying to reclaim the term
selfishness I think part of the way it
gets a bad rap is people are presented
with a false choice and the false choice
is either I give up my values the things
I really care about the stuff that makes
me happy for the sake of other people or
else they I so I'm so I'm losing and
they're gaining apparently or else it's
a victimized other people and the ideas
I'm somehow gaining by that and they're
losing and those are your two choices so
you can be selfless without itself and
then you were sort of like a patsy and
you give up everything for the sake of
other people or else you're selfish and
that means you're exploiting and taking
advantage of other people and she says
this is a false choice and I think
that's really important to get its it
and both are not selfish so if you're
really thinking about your self-interest
neither is the way to pursue it right so
there has to be some kind of third alter
and what she's putting out is a third
alternative then you can live a life
that you're aimed at your own happiness
that's radically non exploitative so you
don't think of other people as prey so
I'm glad that you mentioned the term
self lists which seems like the reverse
of selfish because it seems like we live
in a time right now where with all the
virtues signaling and everything that's
coming out of this sort of social
justice warrior crew that there's
there's
a facade of selflessness as if they're
doing all these things to be selfless
but I would argue they're doing it
probably because of some deep need
within them it may not be scratching
that itch but but how did the idea of
selflessness become so thought of is so
obviously right well that goes way back
and I will say I don't think that you
know it's a separate discussion but I
don't think that all of these social
justice warriors or whatever you want to
call something I don't think they're all
necessarily seeing themselves that a lot
of them are seeing themselves as
virtuous I think some of them are
virtuous I don't think they see it all
in terms of being selfless and there's
some real good that can be done for
certain causes but that's appreciate you
know I mean think of Christ think of
scripture and certainly other religions
and other philosophies have this as well
but you know it's do for God or do for
your other you know I am my brother's
keeper there's something greater than me
I mean the individually you as you has
often just from religious traditions
been no no you know you are a lucky
wretch that God loves you you know and
if you're lucky if you earn salvation
how do you earn it by serving others by
serving the Lord by serving us so it's
sort of been drilled out of people just
for centuries and I mean it goes back in
that sense yeah as to people that that
do this for a living and get in and out
of these ideas what techniques have you
found to take a young person who's been
so taught that either being selfless is
the right thing to do or doing for
others is the right thing to do and
putting yourself secondary or that the
greater good all of those phrases yeah
you have any tricks to kind of wake
people up to some of this I'm not sure
it's exactly a trick but I think there's
a question that it's not easy to ask and
you can help people ask which is why so
why do you have to do these things why
is it that the nation counts more than
you and so you're asking where this
comes from yeah it has deep deep origins
I think in religion and even prior to
that when you look in philosophy and
goes it's for centuries and centuries if
you just think of the Republicans and
the Democrats but you basically can take
any president in his State of the Union
when he's trying to say like this is
morally what you should do live for a
cause greater than yourself greater than
your desires that was george w bush ask
not what you can do at what your country
can do for you ask what you can do for
your country so there's always this kind
of conception that there's something
higher above you it can be God the
nation your race and so and your
obligations are to that and to sacrifice
with you why well no it's and it's a
yeah I think it's that's so important
because these ideas of selflessness and
service are so taken for granted people
don't know why they're supposed to think
but they know that they are mm-hmm
we know it's like whoo this is what I'm
supposing I think what everybody thinks
this everybody respectable everybody
like about everybody good everybody
decent you know so but it is this
article of faith much more than a
product of reason so I mean what you try
to do with anybody be its is a get them
to start questioning but I think another
thing sometimes it's helpful is think
about some of the concrete virtues you
know think about honesty and how that
might be self-interested really or
justice and how it might be
self-interested or certain alleged
virtues may be armed with their cracked
up to be if you actually think about
them in very specific kinds of
circumstances and that's something I
know that with students you know they
can relate to the justice of dealing
with roommates who don't pull their
weight around the house and do the
dishes when they're supposed to do the
dishes or whatever right so just being
selfless in that case and always
cleaning up after your roommate would
not be the wisest thing for you nor your
own or the other roommate or anyone all
right it will be stupid you'd be a patsy
how is it yeah I mean what most people
and you were speaking of the three
alternatives well I'm either gonna
exploit you or just be a sucker right
right
and Rand is offering a third alternative
but in a sense I think of it sometimes
there's a fourth alternative because
another alternative that most people say
boy I gotta be selfish sometimes
you know of course stooop you know you
gotta take care of yourself you gotta go
to the doctor whatever and
of course you got to put others first so
it's a balance you met you know you play
exploiter
sorry I mean that's their version right
and what you saying this is it's not a
zero-sum game
morality having a good life if you
become happy god bless you I don't
believe me God but you know you know you
get the fire I mean that's good that's
great that's know that doesn't mean he
can't be happy that doesn't mean I art
there's no zero-sum there but right
there I guess there's an idea that
somehow if you're selfish that that
precludes other people's happiness that
you're just gonna run em shot of the
world when it seems today I don't think
damn think to anybody else you know I
mean there's much that we do to try to
take good care of ourselves you know on
a regular basis that has nothing to do
with ripping off other people or
anything like but again if you're really
thinking about what does a person's
well-being what is in their interest if
you're really thinking about that as
opposed to well we've got these
throwaway lines about it then you have
to start taking seriously what might be
required so is that the key part of this
then that most people just don't think
these things through so if you ask the
average person well are you selfish then
I say no if you've attacked them and
then if you but if you really whittled
it down to well how do you live your day
do you mostly do things that make your
day go well basically be it at work or
at home or anything else they well
usually they'll say yes if they're
living somewhat of a decent life yeah
and I think part of what happens with
what the demonization of selfishness
it's part of the whole split that
there's morality and there's
practicality so you can either be moral
or practical or as Tara was saying it's
sometimes you want to be moral so you're
gonna be selfless and give up things but
most of the time you wanted to stuff
that's practical and throw my life and
but it's put in a completely different
category and what Iran is saying is it's
hard to be practical to really devote
yourself to your life and if you do that
it's moral and so she's uniting two
things than most people she would say
Farsi that's the most moral thing
yeah and it's hard that's part of what's
different in her conception I think here
again you know one of the caricatures of
selfish you're just saying do what you
want to do do whatever you feel like
doing
now again think about that try that for
a week I'm not gonna study for the test
I don't feel like it yeah I'm not gonna
go to the dent I don't hate going to the
dentist do that you know I mean live
that way oh I don't feel like thinking
about what I can actually afford and how
much money is in the bank and so yeah
see how that works out for you I mean no
it takes thought and think about I
sometimes use these examples of where
it's really clear you want to do its
best for you're trying to decide which
college to go to let's say you've
decided to go to college okay you know
there's a range of considering how much
does it cost how far away is it how good
are they and the subjects I'm interested
in you know there's right what's the
culture like at that country is it too
big am i good you know there's a lot of
stuff to weigh where even though the
objective is I want to do it's gonna be
best for me that might be clear
unequivocal in your mind doesn't mean
it's a no-brainer what's gonna be best
for you people and people face that's
just one example I mean you know medical
treatments in some cases should I take
this job there are a number of cases
where it's not transparent it's not
always easy it sometimes takes
discipline to you know beyond that paleo
diet or make that marathon and train for
it and so on so we're not saying just
always take the shortcut or something
like that right I suspect if you
remember when Mother Teresa died years
ago that basically said that on her
deathbed she was realizing that she
wasn't as happy basically and that she
had had doubts all along I suspect that
wouldn't surprise you as someone that
tried to live for others all the time
yeah I think she had when you read some
of her Diaries no doubts about what
she's doing I think part of the doubts
are its I've given up everything and
there's the big question of why is
there's really no reason to do it and
you need to event a God and all the
particulars of it that the God wants you
to sacrifice and give up your things and
it's you don't have been
reason really to do it you've never been
given a reason yours it's that's part of
what the faith is that I'm gonna
subordinate myself to this higher it's
alleged higher power I'm and to live a
life like that you're gonna have doubts
did I might ever link any of this to
just how we're wired that if you leave
some people to their own devices purely
that they will do some of the the shady
or selfish stuff let's say that it's not
just because not everyone operates in a
purely rational way of thinking all the
time do you know about it if there was
any connection to it I mean I wouldn't
put it as it's exactly wired but it's
sort of a default in that it's a real
achievement to think so just to think
and then gate and think what is right
and wrong what is true and false that's
an achievement it's not you have to do
something wrong and most people do that
automatically and you have to be doing
something wrong to me that is a positive
achievement that the person has to
choose and if he doesn't choose to do
that then I think there's all kinds of
defaults that he's gonna follow what
other people do he needs some kind of
guide and he's not in this idea of self
responsibility he's not his own guy he's
not figuring out what to do
so the typical thing is to look to other
people and that easily then can become
your sort of living for other people are
telling you what to do it's the
authority and taking order kinds of
things and it leads to so she has a lot
from that perspective I think but she
thinks of it as a sort of default of
you've got this tremendous capacity that
you could choose to realize and you
could make something of your life and if
you don't then there's all kinds of
things that that happen doing your own
thinking is one of the major virtues
that she talks about she talks about in
terms of Independence but it's you know
you've got to do your own thinking learn
from it be open to and you can learn
tremendously from others but you've got
to think it all through for yourself
whether it's on moral issues and how I
should leave my life for what I should
do or whatever that's actually one of
her central selfish virtues is do we do
your own thinking try to understand for
yourself so that you can make good
decisions about what's true what's real
what's right what's moral what's going
to serve my well-being am I happy yeah
are you guys particularly enthused at
this moment for
of these ideas because when I hear you
say that about people thinking for you I
mean you know I'd like to think I'm a
little part of something that's
happening online right now where people
are doing it doesn't mean they're all
objective isn't chassé or anything else
but there does seem to be a resurgence
especially amongst young people when
I've done events where they are I I meet
all sorts of young people who maybe
agree on this or disagree on that and
they're every color and race and
sexuality and all of that stuff better
thinking again and I don't know that if
I was doing this exact thing say ten
years ago that it would have been as
influential or effective yeah I mean I
think it's a very positive sign that
there's these I mean you do long-form
stuff with deep conversations and it
gets the big audience and the eyes are
yeah I actually think that part of
what's going on when you're thinking of
the young people it's this is what they
expected college to be more like and
unfortunately college is not like that
anymore it was I think more when I was
still a student undergraduate student
than it and so this deep exploration of
ideas ideas I haven't encountered before
I might not agree with but it takes work
to even just listen and like what's this
other perspective and let me think about
it in the space to think and you're not
supposed to just fall into lockstep with
everybody else there's too much of that
now so I think the fact that you've got
an audience and other people it's it's
really are you seeing sort of a
resurgence of an interesting ideas
somewhat I mean even though I'm at a big
University at the University of Texas I
often teach small classes and somewhat
selective honors classes often at least
so it's in that sense I can't give you a
you know the most representative
spectrum but I definitely see for
instance I've had free speech dialogues
for several years I was hosting these
sorts of things and just as Onkar was
saying people were students all sorts of
students attended and really responded
positively again
in the sense that they really seemed
like they wanted to engage with
different ideas and I do think you're
right that 10 or 20 years ago there
wouldn't have been as much interest in
hearing other ideas but I think it's
just
bankruptcy of the reigning philosophies
the reigning political philosophies and
moral philosophies and the fact that
this selfless net you know really be
selfless and serve it even though that's
still you know what you're supposed to
think of when everybody says how long
can you I mean you have to cheat on that
in order to actually live you have to be
Prudential or practical as Onkar was
saying right how long can people cheat
and people are I mean enough people and
often young people are honest enough
with themselves to realize maybe we need
some different broader theories here
about what is good in bed and maybe
there is more to be said for
self-interest or yeah so you both
mentioned morality here so let's try to
link selfishness to morality so
obviously okay just look at America we
live in a country about 350 million
semi-people who have all sorts of
different moral beliefs does that then
complicate a society's ability to
operate in a selfish way because people
have people are their bedrock of
morality is starting in a different spot
I think it does so and if you think back
to the founding of America you need it's
not everybody has to agree with this but
you need a significant minority who
thinks that the pursuit of happiness is
a good thing to engage it and you can
have different conceptions of all the
details of what that happiness consists
in so and the founding fathers were
creating a system which you're free and
so you have enormous amount of latitude
of how the kind of life you're gonna
build and so on but if there's if it you
really have a perspective that it's a
sin to pursue your own happiness and to
exhibit so another one of Iran's virtues
pride I mean so and pride is about
making something of yourself and you can
I mean put it very colloquially you can
look in the mirror and have a moral
approval like I'm morally good to have
that and that takes work to achieve that
if that's regarded as a sin then I think
the whole system political system that
the founding fathers designed there's
something deeply
problematic about it and what you saw in
the 19th and into the 20th centuries
with the rise of fascism communism
various forms of socialism I think was
targeted at it's selfish to pursue your
own happiness and it is and yeah I mean
freedom is what's you know once you're
talking about a society of an organized
political society I mean what allows
people to have great variations in the
gods that they pray to or whether they
pray at all in the moralities that they
practice what allows that is a common
commitment to individuals freedom but
that's incompatible and this was one of
the things that Iran you know was really
I think insightful on you can't defend
that idea that your life is yours and
you have a right to it if you think oh
no it's not it belongs to this God or
that God or these people or society it's
like but so no one who are losing
freedom again that's another political
conversation have right but no wonder
when will the underpinnings the moral
underpinnings are being lost you briefly
touch on the phrase rational
self-interest do you see any is there
any distinct difference between rational
self-interest and selfishness or is it
just another way of saying I just think
them as the same yeah you know truth
genuine selfishness I mean is yeah yeah
do you think that so that's a little bit
of a branding thing right I mean if the
word selfishness is gonna scare a
certain amount of people I think
rational self-interest sounds maybe a
little more palatable to a certain
amount of people yeah yeah it's part
branding and I think it's important that
she's in the cell ID yeah she didn't
only use selfishness she used rational
self and she used pursuit of happiness
as well so it's not like she's saying
this is the term you have to use don't
use any of these others but I think
she's using selfishness to be
deliberately controversial deliberately
provocative but in a very deep way and
that goes back to some what we're
talking about that people's attitude
disorders we know what selfishness means
you don't dine rent and her perspective
is exactly the reverse I know what it
means you don't you lump all kinds of
people together under this rubric
selfish and they're so different and
some of these people are good and some
of these people about you don't really
have a concept of what selfishness means
and this is how to think
about it properly and that's what she's
trying to do in the book so it's
deliberately provocative but there's a
deep point about like I understand this
better than you do and and people think
the reverse so that's a good segue then
to altruism how do we fit in how much
should you say do for others because a
certain amount of people are gonna watch
as these guys I get it okay but what are
they doing for other people than if
they're just doing things for themselves
okay weird you can get to that that
definition that more narrow definition
of selfishness well Rand and I agree
with her completely opposes altruism by
which I mean you know the elevation of
others above oneself you know up the
valley you know presuming that there is
greater value in another person or the
need of another person Trump's my life
my needs my values right that's what
she's against now that's not the same
thing as being against ever helping
other people or it's certainly not
against but never again they think oh
you're just a solipsistic isn't even the
word I'm looking for you know you just
you don't like other people or yeah
you're antisocial no not are you kidding
again think of it think about your life
I don't know about you but I love you
know their individual you get to know
some people and yeah that goes away
but would your is your life better I
mean just broadly again to start right
is your life generally better because
about people good things they came up
with the fantasy football no I mean
there's no I mean they came up don't get
me started but you can value other
people you can have very different kinds
of relation mean there are some people
who will become good friends there are
some people you'll love from that I mean
my god you're in love with this person I
mean there are people are you just like
for you know as a tennis partner or as a
student or we have all sorts of
relationships and then there's their
circumstances or watch it make sense to
do things for those people but not as a
sacrifice not at the expense of okay
I'll give to him because he needs it now
dammit I'm not going to get to do that
serious thing I've been wanting to do
and say
to do and so that's what she's against
yeah self-sacrifice putting others first
but they're met and one of the things I
talk about I have a book which talks a
lot about rands version of selfish
virtues and I have a section in there or
I talk about generosity and charity and
where they shine it because they're not
virtues for her but nor are they now
shalt nots you know oh my god that would
be a mortal sin and you know how can I
tell you're gonna be excommunicated No
so there are certain virtues in and of
themselves but they're they're not
obligations they're not standing
obligations you know when the
opportunity arises you must give yeah
sorry yeah no no I get it I get it I get
into it no I think that that's really
interesting I mean yeah it's good so you
were asking a little bit before about
thinking of this from a more biological
perspective and I think part of the way
she thinks about it is so the whole
issue of fact and value comes from
biology so when you think about living
things you think about them as having
values that is some things are good for
them and some things bad some things
beneficial some things harmful and that
any living thing I'm gonna plant if you
don't water it for two weeks is that
good or bad for it and everybody has
this perspective while it's obviously
bad for and any living thing you look at
like that and it's true of human beings
as well and it's how you should look at
your own life that there's values in the
world that I have to pursue given that
I'm a human being but the the
selfishness as exploitation the idea is
it's dog-eat-dog um and that's what
she's rejecting completely and I think
this is what's radically different about
human beings that we're capable of
training and so her principle she calls
it the trader principle it's that you
you should be giving value for value
with other people so you should seek out
other people it's not just okay they
happen to be here so I'll go talk to
them so seek out you there's all kinds
of values you can you can learn from
them there's companionship and there's
trade and specialization and so on I
mean look the civilization we live in
you couldn't live in like each person on
a desert island it's ridiculous but
there's a vast vast difference if you're
dealing
someone where you're both profiting from
the relationship or only one person is
and if it's if it really is win lose
whatever the direction it's not a good
relationship and we're capable of having
win-win so that's particularly
interesting to me because I think a lot
of people think you can't have a win-win
situation I think a lot of people think
in the terms of if I'm getting something
as if there's a finite amount of
something I have to take in and I will
now have that right we're not just like
animals who have to scavenge and oh no
there's only so much meat and if this
wolf gets it this one long or something
it's like no we create values and this
was obviously well as anybody who's read
ran knows major theme it's our minds our
use of reason that enables us to create
the values not just find them somewhere
who good got there first right create
the things that we need to survive to
flourish to enrich our lives to make our
lives so good right and so I I mean
again you just think of some of your
best relationships now again that's
starting with your best relationships
right but hopefully I don't I don't know
if you're married or what you're some
aeration it right but it's pretty windy
it's good for the two of you right I
mean we're friends yeah I think it's you
know they're all sort of relationships
again less person not the best one but
you know not just to focus on the very
best ones where hey this is good this
guy likes being a butcher I like is meat
or what you know whatever it might be
yeah and think how bizarre it so there's
this common view that love is selfless
think if you really try to spell it out
and this is you're asking like for for
tips for people ask what like what does
that mean and why is this true and what
it would really mean is you're in a
relationship with another person and you
would be telling them look I don't get
anything from this relationship I don't
really know why a minute but you seem to
be benefiting so that makes it good
right
that way - and then yeah yeah I mean
it's you can't when you really project
it yeah it doesn't make sense and when
she talks about trade so she means it
both in an economic and material values
but also spiritual values you gain from
being around good people and gain in a
way just not like in your pocketbook
it's exactly right I think sometimes the
word trade does have those narrowly
economic connotations and it's not like
oh you calculate how much you get you
know the more good successful people are
around you the richer the pool from
which we all have to benefit I mean I
will write just all you know thinking of
another natural win-win that's great if
the woman who wrote all the Harry Potter
books is richer than - or whatever
she bought a hell of a lot of pleasure
and so on to other be right
I will frequently write an author if I
really like their I might be fiction or
whatever you know or a singer a
performer I really like that's great you
know that she's getting the accolades or
she's getting the money and I really
enjoyed this book or that concert so
it's win-win that's I see it as a an
application in a way of justice of
respecting what I think somebody
desserts like wow that was really that
was out of the ordinary in my view so I
just want to tell them that
lots of win-win out there so when
someone says well wait a minute
JK Rowling has made hundreds and
hundreds and millions of dollars and
nobody could possibly need that much
money she didn't get it because she
needed it she knew she got it because
people wanted to but they thought I'm
better off I want that book I actually
haven't read those but I've been reading
her mysteries which I like very much
there's a plug for you now hey man and
she worked hard to do that and it were
and it's and people want it so they want
to pay so it's and if you think about
the question which she has more money
than she needs that only seems like a
criticism if you have the zero sum
so it's she's amassed so much and that
means other people are losing out but
what you should want if and again this
is if you're selfish you should want
everybody doing what she's
like you should want more people like
that more people like Bill Gates more
people like Steve Jobs I mean think of
how Steve Jobs transformed the world
with the iPhone it's and would you like
you want to get rid of him or you want
10 more people like him and just from
the perspective of your life and your
benefitting it's for sure I would rather
have 10 more than try to take him and
then discourage these potential 10 up
comers because look when he gets really
successful which is what happened Bill
Gates we're gonna go after it right it's
it's in their interest to be free like
that it's in my interest to be right
because everyone wants to be that person
if you're living a sensible if you want
to do something not because necessarily
you just want to be rich you want to do
something now you thing let's try to
bring this into a little bit of what's
happening right now you know there's
always talk about taxes now and
Alexandria
Acacio Cortes talking about this 70%
marginal tax rate and I saw this really
interesting Twitter thread where someone
took the rock they said you know Dwayne
Johnson he makes you know 250 million
dollars a year and then they tried to
break it down what it would look like if
he was having to pay all these taxes and
because you know over 10 million then
it's at 70% basically after this long
Twitter thread they got it down to
something like even if he's making 250
and we tax him out the wazoo who made 35
million dollars a year and who couldn't
live on that and I just was reading and
I thought that just doesn't make it
right makes you kind of feel good so we
sort of outsourced our brains on this in
a way well I think it it it's there's a
little - feeling good about something
that has nothing to do with you or
something but it's it's you're making
him sacrifice you're making him give up
values for other people and that's
supposed to be good so they think of it
as they're doing something good but it
comes from a view that selfishness is
wrong and being selfless is right and if
someone's not going to be do it
voluntarily we're gonna force him right
do it which is directly correlated to
just state power in the role of
government which obviously I ran talk
- what about some of this is just that
we live in a way in a society where we
have outsourced our virtue so that you
know it's like if the government does
everything and the government takes care
of poor people whether they do it well
or not is a separate issue that we don't
have to do certain things that perhaps
if we lived in a society that was a
little freer we might actually do more
and feel good about it mm-hmm well we'd
have to think more it goes back to some
of what we were talking about much
earlier in the conversation I think yeah
there's a lot of outsourcing of
conscience both to the government and to
just society in general like in there's
a sense in which it's easy to be the
altruist of the selfless you say all the
things that all the respectable people
say right you give variations of those
you were reading or mentioning some of
the kinds of things that State of the
Union addresses or commencement
addresses all right so you seem like one
of the you know one of the with it guys
or whatever right so whether it be we
outsource it to government - well yeah I
have a guilty conscience so tax me so
that I'm fulfilling my duty but then I
can still go by the person I want to buy
or whatever it might be again oh we see
it you know are we serious about do you
want to be a good person you got to
think about what it is to be a good
person but from the more positive end -
I think we you want to be happy do you
think you think it's a good thing for
people to be happy hos again say you
know like if you wrote okay then we have
to seriously think about how you're
gonna get that how is anybody gonna be
happy and I know for me one of the real
turning points as I was discovering
objectivism and and coming around - yeah
the self-interest you know on the right
understanding and her is really goodness
when it when it clicked for me and yet I
had been thinking about it a while like
you can't make other people happy this I
think this is really important there's
all sort of things you can do for other
people and that can be of substantial
serious benefit to other people right
but I can't make you a happy person I
can't make you fulfilled I can't make
what it's like to be you feel good - you
feel fulfilling feel rewarding feel like
this is a life worth I can't give that
to even if I love if I know you really
well I like to do everything one you
know there's more to say there but it's
like but if that's the case then the
only way for anybody to be happy to have
the best life they can house for them to
go after it for themselves and that's
gonna take again really thinking maybe
I'm a client how do you then I do do for
somebody so let's say oh there are
circumstances in which you can you know
your rich uncle can pay for your tuition
you know I mean they're right you can be
the good friend who really listens and
tries to understand and you know I mean
so there are a variety of ways in which
we do benefit again we're talking
earlier about relationships as
potentially real win winners right so
there are all sorts of things you can do
but you've got to know what what
somebody else can't give me you know
what some it's like ah that comes from
let's say I'm learning chess okay quick
example you're teaching me chess and now
it's the first times I'm actually gonna
go have a match with this guy over there
right and you're like in the room food
meal that you know you tell me
everything to do I do
can I beat him uh-huh am I gonna feel
good
am I gonna be learning anything like am
I really getting ahead I won right but
it's like so it's some I mean that's a
rough analogy for you got to do it for
yourself you have to lead your life and
you know thinking about what's gonna
make me fulfilled happy feel good you
know what's actually gonna be me using
my resources my capacities and growing
and self-realization and all that that's
the kind of thing somebody's got to do
for themselves they could still have
great relationships with others and that
can be part of you know them building
their good lives yeah so a lot of those
it comes down to the right way if
parenting probably do which is that you
just want to give this person that you
brought up into the world the right
tools so that they can go ahead and
figure it out for themselves
yeah and to really handing them a bag
full you know do whatever
yeah and I think it's the parenting and
wider education I mean we're both
teachers and it's we both know there's a
lot of things you can do to help
students learn but if they're not
putting in the work there's not you
can't shove the knowledge into their
mind
and if we're thinking about valuing as
it requires a lot of knowledge and of
really thinking things through is this
the right career for me is this really
worth doing is this producing the value
and having a first-hand view about that
you can't shove that into somebody's
head he has you can help him see certain
things but they have to do a lot of work
and you're trying to encourage them and
show them like there's an end result
that's really positive but they have to
put in the work and this is the both I
think Iran thinks of two virtues as
virtues the moral traits of character
that most people don't they might think
of him again as practical but not as
moral and that's you need to be rational
which is really think things through for
yourself don't be too quick to just
agree with everyone else do I really
understand things and to be really
pursuing and loving knowledge and then
to be making stuff to be producing and I
think that's the most distinctive and it
goes back to this she views life as
trade when you're interacting with
people you can create new values and if
to go back to the Cortes the 70% she's
seen as moral because she's gonna take
somebody else's money and give it to
somebody else and the guy who's created
it is not seen as moral and he has no
say about what happens to his money
after yeah cuz he made it is the money's
here because I already did that's
enslavement in something but somehow
bono this is moral this is oh yeah this
is the higher ground that I should all
be on well it also says some of I
suppose comes down to that a certain
amount of people think that they can
control the universe or something to
that effect right like she's trying to
build a system that if she could only
build her perfect system we would all
behave in the way you word for that
right well I'm not polite to say of you
know Saint Cortez right right right
right well we just opened the YouTube
comments up hey
let's link this though to justice as
long as we're talking about Cortes and
you mentioned justice we're not everyone
that watches my show knows how
frustrated I am with the social justice
song but as you alluded to earlier there
are it's not Oh first off I would never
argue that it's it's totally malko can
show the show I think most of these
people I think that they're doing good I
think they're ultimately what they're
creating is not good but where does
justice well I guess how would you
define justice and where would it fit
into this conversation
justice is definitely one of the central
virtues in rands account of selfish
virtues she says justice is a matter of
judging other people objectively and
treating them accordingly so it in växjö
you know couple parts to that right
you're it does involve judging people as
opposed to judge not and be not judged
or who are you to be judgmental or who
do you to join all that no no you have
to judge individuals right people don't
judge me but I do this and notice that
if you're good
you're not gonna say don't judge me but
if you don't like things about you right
but it's again judge objectively so you
have to go by the evidence and sometimes
you don't have enough evidence so don't
judge prematurely you don't be like oh I
got to reach a judgment I don't know
enough yet or I don't have enough to go
or whatever so you have to judge judge
objectively and act accordingly treat
the person as he deserves and yeah so
it's definitely a virtue it's a virtue
again it's an application of being
rational as unkar was talking about
earlier it's be real let's talk about
people people vary in many many
different respects it's not just a
matter of judging their moral character
right I have to judge my mechanic gee
every time I bring the car to that guy I
always have to bring it back three weeks
late or where that right or this place
charges too much for whatever it might
be right you judge roommates again you
know college roommates whatever kind of
guy who should I who should I have
babysit the kid I mean we judge people
for all sorts of things minor major you
know very consequential or not it makes
sense for your own self-interest
try to be very clear-eyed in the
judgments that you make and you know
I'll give my business there or not no
I'm really interested in that person
let's see if she wants to go out
Saturday night or whatever it might so
you judge people you treat no objective
win so if we live in a society though
where people have a different moral
bedrock and I know that even though
you'd love for everyone to live by these
rules obviously you're not gonna close
it I might know that much
how do we get a consistent definition of
what justice is then as a society I
think it has deeper foundation so it and
there has to be some agreement on those
deeper foundations again not every
single person has to agree but you don't
if if you have on the foundational
issues in a in a society everyone
disagreeing about everything you can't
build a call you don't really have a
culture you have a clash and an
ideological clash and I think the Bay
City sort of yes yes and I I think it's
it's because there's various competing
issues there's still the enlightenment
heritage of viewing people as
individuals and that they have control
over their lives over their thinking in
action and I can therefore judge them as
individuals and that justice is a issue
of judging individual by individual you
can have blanket and collective when
we're talking about a tall blocks are
all gazes that there's no such thing if
you're really thinking of yeah yeah guys
and the more you have a again at the
deeper foundations of the culture the
more it's pushing that what your
identity is is your group or it can be
different groups and the more that your
conception of justice is totally
different because you don't think of it
as an individual in control of their
lives and I don't have to judge
individual yeah by individual and if
there's not agreement about that like if
most people think no we're just these
group right that's right people are
exploiters 72% right I'll take yeah
right and this is tremendously what's
happening right now I mean this is what
I would say
sort of oppression Olympics of judging
us by those traits and looking at
somebody and going you have darker skin
so I should think this you're a woman so
I should think this I mean this this
seems to have become mainstream thought
right now so it's funny when I've had
your on Brooklyn a couple times he'll
talk about how well when he goes to
Eastern Europe where they're starving or
ideas they've lived through communism
well they love Iran because they need a
yeah that's just a few nothing like your
owns but a few Eastern European
countries and and spoke in there and
yeah the reality of the alternatives is
more palpable to these people even
younger generations but they remember
their grandfathers farm and you know
that do it all because you didn't have a
freer economy and so on it's all much
more real to them yeah but yeah I think
we've definitely kind of socialized the
idea of justice I mean justice is an
interesting virtue in that it goes way
back and many different cultures East
and West have very strong ideas of
justice and many of them are essentially
this idea of you treat people as they
deserve but it's gradually over the
years been distorted and ideas about
individual dessert Oh dessert no no
individual can deserve anything you know
you are what the community made you you
are just you know it takes a village
you know you didn't build that god
forbid we kind of did in some cases you
know it is the individuals who did but
we it's a sort of transposition of the
anti individualist that's really
perverted justice and in some of these
ways that we're seeing so this has been
a through line through everything we've
done here but let's just bring this to
honesty also and why honesty is so
important it's again I think she has a
very distinctive view so most people
think of honesty back linking it to
selfishness that if I were to be selfish
I'd be dishonest because I'd exploit
other bad lie to them I cheat die I tell
more than once
yeah and so that's what's self it but
honestly well I tell the truth and I'm
interested in the truth for other people
and rands view that I think it's the
it's really important to get that this
is right is you should care about the
truth for yourself so you should be or
conception of honesty is a passionate
commitment that I want to know what's
true about my life in the world and if
I'm in a bad relationship
I don't to fake and pretend that I'm in
a good relationship I'm never gonna get
to be in a good relationship if I don't
face the fact I'm not in a good
relationship all right don't like my job
at work right blue on Facebook will
think you're happier than you are and
that's I mean if you really have a
conception of it's my life I've got one
to live and so on it doesn't matter what
other people think about it and if they
think you're happy or they think you're
not it's okay you know from the inside
you have a perspective on your own life
is it going well or not and part of
honesty is to look at yourself in a deep
way and think do I like everything about
myself are the things that I don't
things that I can improve do I like my
situation in life in thinking about
happiness stuff of I'm in a dead-end
career or I've exotic I liked it but I'm
so now just going through the motions
sort of I need a change and the if you
pretend or fake what do you don't gain
it anything you don't you're still in
this job that you're not really
fulfilling you're pretending to yourself
and maybe other people because you have
to be respectable and you can't have a
midlife crisis or whatever but if that's
what's happening you should really face
it I mean the way I think of it often is
just faking things doesn't change things
you can pretend to other people or to
yourself
right but faking things doesn't change
things so the sooner I figure out what
things are and like face that honestly
the better position I'm in to pursue my
happiness you know to to have a good
life to get out of this relate like and
a lot of it is avoiding self-deception I
think that's really important it's not
the matter of are you honest with do you
tell lies right it's like the road to
hell is paved with evasion of college
anymore just fine you know yeah you
gotta be honest with yourself you got to
be honest you got to try to face facts
and find out when you don't know what's
what so that you can make the best
decisions right so faking isn't gonna
help but again what's interesting I
think is usually when people are taught
well you got to be truthful it's got to
be honest because the reasons given are
well you get a bad reputation if you
found out to be a liar right your
credibility will suffer people won't
want to deal with you or in general this
is bad for the social fabric of trust
reliably you know we need a lot of it
well know that those but those things
are both true but one solution would be
become a better Ally or don't be found
out right it's like no that's not really
gonna help because more fundamentally
than what other people think are your
dealings with other people if you're a
long goddamn desert island not on that
old movie castaway or something like you
gotta be honest about I've got something
here that I think I should worry about I
think there's a storm coming this way
I've gotta follow the facts right I
gotta try the truth if I'm gonna make
rational decisions
so it's a very reality based approach to
honesty yeah faking things doesn't
change them you can lie on the CV and
pretend you you can do something that
you can't good luck when you get in the
job then you know if you can fool people
for a while but you can't fool reality
and then are there moments where being
dishonest is actually within your
rational self-interest I wouldn't put it
as dishonest but if you have to concrete
a view of what honesty and dishonesty
mean then so are there times when I
would lie yes if I mean the kind of
standard examples if some gang is going
around killing people and they ask well
where's your wife or whatever I'm gonna
lie right and and I don't view that as
dishonest so if I think of honesty is
loyalty to the facts well it's okay and
dishonesty is I'm trying to get around
the facts and trying to achieve
something
while getting around the fact I don't
think you can achieve so you can try to
put people off the scent for a minute in
lie to them so I think their situation
that's the standard kind I think there
are other situations where I would lie
because I
someone's trying to invade your privacy
and so on and if you just say no comment
or something like that it it's often
better if you lie and they go off
looking in some direction where they
should so there are situations but I
don't think of that as it's honesty is
about I'm loyal to the facts I want to
know because I need knowledge in order
to guide my life and to succeed in
everything that I'm trying to do and I
think even when you think of it in
regard to other people the reason you
brought up Bernie Madoff before who lied
on a left right center why does he feel
out of control of his own life and when
you read that he it's because as Tara
was saying he knows that he's lying so
these are not facts and the liar
typically thinks I'm so sophisticated
and a good liar and these are all idiots
who can't discover any facts but the
facts are out there to discover and and
you know that and some so viewed
long-term someone's gonna find out the
way he's cooking the books and so and
the more his scheme goes on the more
things there is to find out and he knows
that any experience isn't massive that
he's out of control because he is out of
control right so basically I was
building a house a car yes mother he
might be the one that knocks ya
inadvertently yeah he tells something
that he has to keep his five different
stories straight and he told the wrong
thing to the wrong person who then
starts the question and that's like
inevitable in the situation because the
facts are still there out there for
people to discover it doesn't make it so
yes so that's an interesting way to link
to the final topic that we'll talk about
which is pride so they say pride cometh
before the fall he must have thought
Madoff must have thought I can manage
all this stuff because of these people
as you said they must be idiots and I
can manage all of us but it was his
pride in a way that was almost his
downfall at some level well is well his
I would say is fake pride yeah that's
that that's I think the thing so not his
authentic prop yeah
think it's coming from the right virtue
of Pride and mine but that he had this
he had concocted a system yeah it is
mine that he felt yeah that he's
superior to everybody so he can juggle
this and so I he's capable nobody else's
and so but that is just that's such
massive self-deception I think there's
no reason to think that and you just
think of the investment world there's
all kinds of people like a Warren
Buffett it's all who are like orders of
magnitude a better investor than me if
you were really thinking about there's
no way you could think that I'm I can
dupe everybody about everything and
there were rumors over a lot of long
period of time of people who understood
that there's no way that hid this scheme
is is the Trojans I might not know the
specific fraud but there's no way and a
lot of smart money III yeah a lot of
smart money avoided him and and that
like that's a fact that it's so there's
such self-deception going on and pride
is about developing a character that's
good and therefore you can respect and
he's doing exactly the opposite he's
expecting someone that he can't look in
the mirror and when you read about the
account it's more and more he feels like
that that he's just trying to put
something over on others and that's
where he's seeking his self-esteem by oh
what a good clever guy right now Ryan
talks about pride as a vert right I just
a pride goat you know we're told oh you
know pride is one of the seven deadly
sins she says it's one of you know the
six or seven major virtues what's she
talking about
she's not talking about patting yourself
on the back you know it's not the self
congratulatory oh I'm wonderful you know
get ready for my closet
pride is about mate well she describes
it as moral ambitiousness which i think
is one of the loveliest phrases in her
nonfiction writing trying to be the best
person you can be you referred to making
your character you know we talk of a
self-made man he made his fortune or JK
Rowling made her fortune you make your
character you can make your character as
good as it can be not as an end in
itself but so that you can have the
alright hey I want to really live
according to the principles that make
sense for human happiness for human
beings to have rich flourishing lives
worth living I want to do so if I figure
out what the right principles are I want
to practice those you bet I want to be
perfect now perfect you're not yeah
everybody freaks out and you say the
word but I want to be as good as I can
be you know when I'm 22 years old when
I'm 28 I have different capacities and
so on at different times so it's make
your life as good as it can be be
morally ambitious that means again you
got to be honest with yourself
it doesn't mean you excuse it's like no
no if you realize oh Tara that was not
that's not too good
you've gotta be honest if you really
care about your character your life
being as good as it can be but that's
what she's talking about yeah you should
be proud you should feel good about
yourself when you've earned that
Aristotle said the same thing on that
part
you know you said yeah pride is the
crown of the virtues when you practice
all the other virtues and can honestly
look at yourself in the mirror but what
it's about is not this gaze and it's not
comparative it's not all I'm so much
better than him right yes I want to make
my life as good as it can be I want to
be morally ambitious and if that's
pretty good
it's pretty good oh my gosh I just to
look at it back from the perspective of
the moral and the practical this is when
she's saying they go together most
people fear more a lead or suspicious of
it they because they think of it it's
there to take their values away it's
it's the rock he's made 70 million and
now well to be moral you would give 70
percent of it away so and what her whole
conception is no you live it to the
fullest
so pride is both its moral and practical
and you're trying to unite these things
together so instead of fearing morality
you're interested in and you want to
learn its principles because it's gonna
advance your life it's such a radically
different view of thinking about
morality that is a solid ending my
friend it's been a pleasure chatting
with you guys thanks for watching
everybody
this is just one in a series of six of
these interviews that I'll be doing over
on the iron rain Institute YouTube
channel and you can find a link to that
right down below
[Music]